a former Boston College student returned
to the u.s. from South Korea to face
accusations that she drove her boyfriend
to kill himself in young you pled not
guilty to involuntary manslaughter
charges Friday prosecutors say she sent
a barrage of abusive text messages to
Alexander Tula who then took his own
life
mola link' has the story and how do you
not plead in Jung you stood silently as
a prosecutor read dozens of profanity
filled text messages that she said the
21 year old sent to her boyfriend
Alexander Tula literally I want to bash
your head against the wall
can you go hit your head on the leaf the
21 year old is accused of physically
emotionally and psychologically abusing
her Tula through text messages which
drove him to take his own life on his
graduation day last May the defendants
abuse was the cause of mr. Tula suicide
over the course of the last two months
of their 18 month relationship the
couple exchanged more than 75,000 text
messages more than half were sent from
you prosecutors say she constantly drove
the talk of suicide repeatedly texting
her Tula to go die and in another text
she wrote do everyone a favor and go
effing kill yourself
use defense attorney Steven Kim suicide
is always sad but to further punish the
young woman who loved this man
would only compound the tragedy that
already exists her attorney released
texts earlier this week which they say
shows you tried to stop her Tula
she wrote if you ever effing loved me
stop or Tula responded I did love you
just not well enough goodbye
prosecutors say you was there she was on
the parking garage roof when Tula jumped
they say she knew he was there for
nearly an hour because she tracked his
cell phone location but she never
alerted anyone to intervene in the
suicide you was out on bail and she had
to forfeit her US passport for CBS this
morning Saturday Mobile leggy Boston